so as you guys already know it's been a
couple of months since the launch of the
training series from Nvidia and
unfortunately it was really expensive
and you were willing to pay the price
it really wasn't worth it it was
expected that with the launch of lololol
variants then the situation would get
much better but the performance suspects
and priced our upcoming artix 2060 have
begun to surface I hate to say it it
doesn't look too good
so here's why the Arctic 2060 is more
than disappointed
[Music]
welcome to Horace all these now first of
all let's take a look at the performance
of the upcoming r-tx 2060 our
performance isn't even that bad it's
actually pretty good it's not as good as
the last generation with gap where the
gtx 1060 was able to compete with the
980 however it is definitely a
significant upgrade over to 1060 the
2060 is on level way to 1070 TI in some
games it is slightly slower than the GTX
780 Ti but other games it is
considerably faster so this car is
definitely not lacking in terms of
performance where it is losingest in
terms of price and the fact that has a
rate raising technology first of all
rate racing doesn't even run that well
on the higher level cards like the 2070
2080 and even 28 epi which costs $1,200
so I'm not sure why I decided to include
on this GPU according to leaked the
Arctic's 2060 is supposed to provide
over 60 frames per second with racing on
at least on battlefield 5 now that's
actually pretty good for people who are
gaming at 1080p with the 60 Hertz
monitor
however for everyone who has a 144 her
smarter a 120 Hertz monitor or it's not
gave me a 1080p this is completely
useless and with 144 hurst martyrs being
offered for much less than 200 lives
nowadays the people who are jumping off
to them is quite large overall the great
christian technology offer in the
Arctic's 2060 is only useful to a select
group of people which is quickly
diminishing and by the end of the
lifetime of this GPU that population
will be very small so most architects
2060 owners will just end up turning it
off and it is unnecessary to college
that in media is making us pay for now
don't get
rate ratio technology is a good
technology and will probably be a
standard in the future however at this
current point in time it definitely does
not need to be included in a mid-level
GPU inflating its price and that brings
me into my next point its price the
Arctic's 2060 is supposed to cost three
hundred and fifty dollars that's
literally how much it's at seventy i
cost so I'm pretty confused as to what
this generation is supposed to offer
over the last oh wait as rate range
technologies that everyone can turn off
my back
overall if you guys haven't caught the
theme of this video yet is that the
archives 2060 is fundamentally flawed it
is supposed to be a mid-level GPU but it
is not priced like one and it has great
reason technology which if anything
should be reserved for higher level GPUs
as a result for the vast majority of
consumers there would be no difference
in buying an Arctic 2060 over the gtex
1070 TI they could probably even get the
GTS 1070 TI for cheaper the point of New
York generations is yes to bring newer
technology to enthusiasts but also offer
older technology to the average consumer
for a much more affordable price and
that does not seem to be happening this
generation C last generation the GTX
1060 through gigabyte n6 Quebec card
world wall priced at 200 and 250 dollars
and that's where this card should be
placed as well max $300 but this card is
well over $300 if India didn't include
ray-tracing technology onto this GPU and
priced in the mid 200s then this GP
would actually be pretty good but by
including rate presence technology onto
the GPU and vias forcing is on to us and
forcing us to pay more for something
that we didn't ask for or are going to
use the main purpose of a 60 series card
is to offer good performance at an
affordable price and that is exactly
what the archaic 2060 does not do and
that is exactly why the Arctic's 2060 is
more than disappointing
however fortunately there is hope from
AMD
there are several rumors suggesting that
they're going to be launching your
high-level series which may even match
the performance of some architects cars
but for half the price because it's
price won't being plated by very
creative technology but that's just what
I think what do you guys think what are
your thoughts on the Arctic's 2060 and
are you going to be waiting for a muse
new series make sure to comment down
below what you guys think also if you
guys like to get image drop a like and
consider subscribing if you'd like to
see more videos just like this one
until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one
[Music]